you wake up in new york at 9 00 a.m
and you just found out there is a major
networking event in london
in five hours imagine if you could hop
on a plane
at noon and make it there on time
would be impossible right now by plane
but not
by rocket
elon musk's greatest ambition is to use
starship to build a city on mars which i
talked about in the previous video
and while working on that plan he
thought about another use for the
spacecraft
maybe there is some market for really
fast transport of stuff around the world
that was musk in 2016 and the market has
now expanded to moving not just cargo
but crew if you build a ship that's
capable of going
to mars what if you take that same ship
and go from one place to another on
earth
spacex wants to take people from place
to place on the planet
making most long distance trips in less
than 30 minutes
and going anywhere around the world in
under an hour
while passenger planes travel up to 575
miles per hour
starship will go nearly 17 000 miles per
hour
and instead of flying above the clouds
it'll fly above the earth
the great thing about going to space is
there's no
friction so once you're out of the
atmosphere
you go it will smooth the silk no
turbulence nothing
but that doesn't necessarily mean your
ride will be very comfortable
it will feel sort of like disney's space
mountain roller coaster which means
you'll need some sort of restraint
mechanism
and if you feel a little queasy there
won't be any toilets or other amenities
like a kitchen galley
in order for starship to carry a lot
more people if it were making a trip to
mars there would have to be cabins and
common areas
because it would take months to get
there and that would limit the number of
passengers to 100
whereas earth to earth travel allows
starship to hold 1 000
passengers in order to board the
spacecraft you would need to take a boat
to the site of the rocket launch which
is on a floating platform called a
spaceport
after going beyond earth it re-enters
the atmosphere and arrives at a floating
spaceport in another city
since starship is fully reusable the
price of a ticket will be drastically
reduced
but that doesn't mean it will be cheap
we don't yet know how much a trip will
cost but a cnbc reporter quoted spacex's
president and ceo
quinn shotwell singh at an event in 2019
that it will be cheaper than a first
class ticket
but a little more than economy shotwell
has also said previously that it would
be less than a business class fare
so it's still unclear what the price
will be but here's an example of
round-trip plan tickets from london's
heathrow airport
to new york's jfk about a month from now
an average economy ticket is around four
hundred dollars
for business class it's four thousand
and for first class about five thousand
besides the price there's another big
consideration spacex will need to
address
rockets are really noisy
that's the sound of one raptor engine
that powers starship
there are currently 31 of these planned
for the super heavy booster which lifts
starship into orbit
while another six are located on
starship itself
however musk has said starship could
actually make trips under 6 200 miles
without the need for the booster and
instead the spacecraft would fly with an
additional two to four engines
but because it would still have an
impact on residents the spaceport will
be located 20
miles offshore which means getting there
could take more time
than the actual flight as a comparison
the journey from new york's grand
central terminal to jfk
airport is about 14 miles musk has
suggested a hyperloop transit system
traveling hundreds of miles per hour
could ferry people to the spaceports
really quickly
and while spacex works at all its plans
the airline industry is also trying to
cut down on travel time supersonic
planes which travel faster than the
speed of sound could be returning
the concorde stopped flying in 2003
following spiraling maintenance costs
a company called boom supersonic is now
developing the overture which would cut
flight times by plane in half
so a trip from new york to london would
be 3 hours and 15 minutes
it would be the price of a business
class ticket and the aim is to have
commercial flights by 2030
it's unclear if spacex's earth to earth
plans will be scaled up to take off
before then
but musk says test flights could start
as early as 2022 or
2023 and eventually it will be real
when it is it could change how we live
and even where we live
although we might have to wait a while
the future of air travel
could be in space thanks so much for
watching i'm cindy pom so if you could
afford a trip on starship
would you use it to go to another city
could you stomach the ride
i'd love to hear what you have to say
you can leave a comment in the section
below
by the way i want to take this
opportunity to thank my patrons
if you like what you see give it a like
and don't forget to subscribe to my new
channel
i hope to do a lot more stories on
topics that i find super interesting
and important see you soon